we can consider a given coordinate
system as a reference frame within which
we can describe the kinematics of an
object by the kinematics I mean the
position the velocity and the
acceleration as a function of time
basically a geometric description of the
motion some aspects of these kinematics
will look different in different
reference frames and I'd like to examine
that now first I want to define what I
mean by an inertial reference frame an
inertial reference frame is one in which
an isolated body one with no net force
acting on it moves at constant velocity
where that constant velocity might be
zero another way of saying this is that
an inertial reference frame is one in
which Newton's laws of motion apply
recall that Newton's first law of motion
states that an isolated object with no
forces acting on it moves at constant
velocity so let's begin by considering a
bit observer in a particular reference
frame we'll call that reference frame s
and denoted by coordinate axes x and y
and let's consider an object that in
that court in that reference frame is at
a position vector small R we can then
consider a second reference frame which
I'll call the frame s Prime and I'll
denote that with coordinate axes X Prime
and y Prime in my example gear I'm going
to assume that the coordinate axes in
frame s prime are parallel to but
displaced away from the coordinate axes
in frame s more generally we could have
the S prime coordinate axes rotated with
respect to the frame s axes that's a
complication I'm not going to add now
but conceptually it's not really
different for simplicity we'll stick two
parallel axes in this example so imagine
we have two observers one in frame s at
the origin and one of the origin of
frame s Prime both looking at the same
object the observer s will measure a
position vector little R observer s
prime will measure a position vector
little R Prime the two observers have a
relative position vector capital R which
is the position of s Prime relative to
the origin of frame s so what we would
like to see
is how are these different position
vectors related well from the geometry
of the diagram we can see that the
position measured by observer s which is
just little R is equal to the position
of observer s prime relative to observer
s which is capital R plus the position
vector measured by the observer at s
prime which is little R prime I can
rewrite that if I'd like to write the
position measured by the observer s
Prime in terms of what's measured by the
observer at s I could just rearrange
this and write that little R prime is
equal to little R - capital R now let's
add a further complication and assume
that the observer s prime is not just at
a different location from the observer
of s but is moving at constant velocity
relative to frame s so we'll assume that
frame s prime is moving at constant
velocity with respect to frame s at a
constant velocity vector V ok so V
vector
is a constant and in that case my offset
of observer s prime relative to observer
s which is the vector capital R is a
function of time so capital R is a
function of time and it's given by the
offset at time zero which I will call
capital or not
plus the elapsed motion due to the
constant velocity which is capital V
times time so since capital R is a
function of time that tells me that in
this equation little R Prime the
position vector measured by the observer
in frame s prime is also going to be a
function of time even if capital sorry
even if little R is a constant so notice
what that means if the object is at rest
in frame s the object will appear to be
moving its position vector will be time
dependent in frame s prime because
capital R the location of s prime
relative to s is changing so this
relation tells us how the position
vectors in the two frames are related
what about the velocities well to
compute how the velocities are related
we can just take the time derivative of
the relation of the position vectors so
in this particular case we have that the
time derivative of the s prime position
D little R prime DT is equal to the time
derivative of the position in frame s
which is d little R DT minus the time
derivative of the offset of s prime
relative to s so that's minus D capital
R DT and I can rewrite that in terms of
symbols for the velocity so I have here
the velocity little V prime which is the
velocity measured by an observer in
frame s Prime and that's equal to the
velocity little V which is the velocity
measured by frame s
- d capital r dt which we see is just
capital v vector which is the velocity
of s prime relative to s so this is how
the velocities are related and again
notice that if the object is stationary
in one frame it will still have a will
be so if it's zero in one frame it will
be nonzero in the other frame so in
general you will measure different
velocities in the different frames even
if one of those velocities is zero now
how are the accelerations related well
again we can just take the time
derivative of the velocities to figure
out what the relationship of the
accelerations is so differentiating this
equation I have that D little V prime DT
is equal to D little V DT minus D
capital V DT but here something
interesting happens because remember we
said that capital V is a constant vector
and remember capital V is the velocity
that frame s prime has relative to frame
s okay so since capital V is a constant
that means that this term goes to zero
and so we see that the acceleration in
frame s prime is equal to the
acceleration in frame a so if I have two
reference frames one moving at a
constant velocity relative to the other
in general I will measure different
positions and different velocities for
an object as measured by the two frames
however the accelerations measured in
both frames will be identical because
the accelerations are identical we'll
see that Newton's laws will look
identical in the two frames and we can
see that in the following way in frame s
we have that the force is equal to the
mass times the acceleration in frame s
I'm the force f prime is equal to the
mass times a prime but a prime is equal
to a as we calculated here so we see
that the forces in the two frames are
identical even though the positions and
velocities in general will be different
as measured in the two frames for the
same object but the accelerations will
be identical and so the forces will be
identical so if one of these reference
frames is an inertial frame one in which
an isolated body moves at constant
velocity then any other frame moving at
constant velocity with respect to the
first frame will also be an inertial
frame what this means is that you are
always free to transform from one
inertial frame to another and what that
means is that you can always transform
to another frame that is moving at
constant velocity with respect to an
original inertial frame